bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre à
strasbourg pour l'entretien de france 24
avec la toute nouvelle présidente du
parlement européen il s'agit de la
maltaise roberta mezzo là bonjour madame
la présidente troisième femme à ce poste
je rappelle que vous êtes du parti
populaire européen c'est le parti donc
plutôt à droite de l'hémicycle mais vous
avez reçu une très large majorité pour
votre mandature de la part des sociaux
démocrates des libéraux un mandat de
deux ans et demi sur fond de pandémie
finalement et et de conflits aussi à nos
portes quelles vont être vos priorités
105 kg aux états mais si c'est un
honneur et un privilège mais aussi une
responsabilité d'être élu pour deux ans
et demi ce sera un vrai défi après une
période difficile dont nous sommes
lentement mais espérons le en train de
sortir
ces deux prochaines années seront
dominées par les activités législatives
elles seront dédiés aux priorités du
numérique du changement climatique de
l'immigration des thèmes sur lesquels
nos citoyens veulent que nous
travaillons
mercredi la cour de justice a rendu sa
décision permettant de sanctionner la
pologne et la hongrie pour non respect
de l'état de droit pour le parlement
européen cet arrêt était très attendu et
nous resterons vigilants afin de nous
assurer que la commission et les autres
institutions européennes fassent
respecter l'application de la loi et
répondre aux questions que nous leur
avons posé par exemple sur l'état de
droit dans ces pays sur l'initiative
législative pour le parlement européen
est aussi sur la mise en oeuvre des
conclusions de la conférence sur
l'avenir de l'europe c'est 60 de filles
beaucoup d'ambition que nous devons
concrétiser en même temps une une
dramaturgie quand même à l'extérieur de
nos frontières la russie qui fait
entendre un bruit de bottes en direction
de l'ukraine à nos portes est-ce que
vous allez être aussi une voix forte de
la diplomatie européenne d'une
diplomatie plus engagé
oui absolument ce parlement a déjà été
le lieu d'un franc très concret et unie
et nous l'avons vu avec la présidente de
la commission le président du conseil
européen et le haut représentant qui se
sont exprimées d'une seule voix devant
l'hémicycle afin de montrer que l'union
européenne reste unie
les présidents des groupes politiques se
sont également mis d'accord récemment au
sein de ce parlement sur une position
politique forte affirmant notre
solidarité vis-à-vis du peuple ukrainien
nous avons voté une aide d'un virgule 2
milliards d'euros dans la microfinance
mais aussi une position commune clair
maintenant que nous avons demandé une
désescalade s'il inverse venait à se
produire notre réponse serait concrètes
rapides et efficaces
c'est la france qui détient ce semestre
européen la présidence tournante du
conseil de l'union européenne
c'est une présidence compliqué parce
qu'elle est évidemment vous le savez
entrecoupées par des élections
présidentielles en france est ce que
vous croyez à des résultats concrets et
sur quel chapitre en particulier vous
voulaient accélérer le travail
nous avons de très grands espoirs pour
cette présidence du conseil et bien
qu'elle n'ait commencé qu'il ya six
semaines nous avons déjà vu d'importants
progrès à la fois sur les deux
directives sur les marchés et services
numériques le digital market act et le
dj torres avait ses actes ce sont deux
grandes priorités à la fois pour ce
parlement et pour la présidence
française
deuxièmement nous avons aussi vu du
changement et nous espérons qu'il y aura
des avancées sur la question migratoire
ceux qui avancent beaucoup en ce moment
c'est tout ce qui concerne le paquet
climat
ces questions nous ont été transmises
elles sont portées par la présidence
française et nous nous attendons à des
positions ambitieuses non seulement
avant l'élection présidentielle dans
votre prise mais jusqu'au 30 juin à la
fin de la présidence française de
l'union européenne
et il ne faut pas oublier que le 9 mai
c'est la remise des conclusions de la
conférence sur l'avenir de l'europe
mais aussi
et aussi le jour où nous recevrons les
conclusions de la conférence sur
l'avenir de l'europe nous les
examinerons et nous les transmettrons au
sein du parlement pour commencer à
travailler dessus vous savez sur france
24 nous faisons la chasse à la
désinformation et aux seins fox et je
vous prie de d'en regarder une qui
traite de l' usage du français dans les
institutions européennes
c'est une info qs véhiculée par un
candidat à la présidentielle française
on regarde
parle-t-on systématiquement anglais dans
les réunions des institutions
européennes c'est ce qu'eric zemmour a
laissé entendre à la mi janvier lors
d'une interview je demanderai que les
réunions européennes cesse d'être
systématiquement en anglais il ya
d'autres langues en europe
et on n'a pas besoin de parler en
anglais maintenant que les anglais ne
sont plus là
dans les faits même si les britanniques
ont quitté l'union l'anglais reste une
des langues officielles de l'irlande et
de malte soit 1,2 pour cent des
européens alors hégémonique l'église au
parlement européen les 24 langues
officielles des pays de l'union ont le
même statut et sont traduites lors des
plénières chaque député européen peut
s'exprimer dans la langue européenne de
son choix au conseil européen
quelle que soit la langue dans laquelle
s'expriment les représentants des états
membres un document résumant les points
importants et les décisions prises lors
des réunions sera publié dans toutes les
langues officielles de l'ue la
commission européenne quant à elle
traite ses affaires internes dans trois
langues procédurales officiel l'allemand
l'anglais est la langue de molière en
2021 un rapport sur la diversité des
langues au sein des institutions
européennes a montré une augmentation de
l'utilisation de l'anglais aussi bien
dans les documents que lors de
discussions informelles
principalement en raison des
visioconférences duo qu'ovide et des
coupes budgétaires sur les traductions
toutefois si par hasard eric zemmour
était amené à s'exprimer en français
dans une institution européenne
il pourrait se faire comprendre sans
problème alors est-ce que vous en tant
que présidente du parlement européen
roberta mazzola vous dites les langues
le pluralisme dans mon institution ça va
revenir les interprètes ils vont revenir
et et notamment on va rester aussi dans
le siège de strasbourg absolutely
absolument la situation n'a pas changé
les vingt-et-une langue officielle
continue à être parler partout nous
interprètes et traducteurs font un
travail formidable
pendant la pandémie ils ont bouleversé
complètement leur façon de travailler
via internet en traduisant à distance et
à partir de différents pays de l'uma oui
nous avons hâte de les voir revenir pour
les sessions plénières avec la
possibilité qu'ils soient physiquement
présents ici dès que ces mesures
extraordinaires seront progressivement
levés
c'est important pour nous et c'est
important pour chacun des membres du
parlement européen et lues ici faut-il
où elle puisse s'exprimer dans la langue
de son pays
parce que leurs concitoyens s'attendent
à ce que les députés parlent dans la
même langue que
pour moi le siège de strasbourg du
parlement c'est extrêmement important ce
n'est pas seulement symbolique mais
c'est le lieu pour le dialogue et la
paix et cela permet de comprendre que
c'est depuis strasbourg que l'europe
envoient ces messages les plus
fondamentaux et adopter les meilleures
lois pour les citoyens revenons
brièvement sur une polémique au moment
de votre élection effectivement la
première femme à présider été simone
veil une icône de la lutte pour
l'avortement ou même vous êtes d'un pays
qui interdit totalement l'avortement et
vous êtes plutôt pro avortement est ce
que ça va poser problème
comme je l'aï dit dans mon discours
inaugural je m'appuie sur la stature de
simone veil c'est une femme qui à briser
le plafond de verre pour être la
première femme à présider le parlement
c'est un honneur pour moi de transmettre
l'héritage de femmes telles que simone
veil et nicole fontaine
comme je les dis immédiatement après mon
élection mais comme je lai aussi prouvé
quand j'étais vice présidente du
parlement la position du parlement
européen y compris sur ce sujet est et
sera ma position alors malte c'est aussi
une île qui est critiqué pour avoir
repoussé les ong de sauvetage des
migrants en méditerranée donc de ses
ports et puis il ya aussi maintenant des
accusations de push back avec l'aide des
garde-côtes libyens est ce que vous
pensez qu'il faut réviser la politique
d'asile et de migration de votre pays d
cela fait bien sûr partie des
discussions que nous avons actuellement
au sein du parlement européen c'est sur
la table et nous allons réviser le pacte
asile et migrations on ne peut pas
parler de solidarité sans la traduire
dans les actes pour moi et cette
position est partagée au sein du
parlement notre politique de migration
doit être objective elle doit être juste
pour les personnes éligibles aux mesures
de protection mais aussi ferme pour ceux
qui ne le sont pas et dur pour ceux qui
se font de l'argent sur le dos des plus
vulnérables nous allons aussi et c'est
le plus important de ce pacte nous
pencher sur la légalité des opérations
de recherche et sauvetage en mer sur les
attributions réelles de frontex l'agencé
européenne des gardes frontières et des
garde-côtes car nous devons garder tout
cela à l'esprit lorsque nous assistons à
des opérations de recherche et sauvetage
que ce soit en méditerranée ou aux
frontières extérieures de l'europe comme
c'est le cas entre la biélorussie et les
pays baltes et toutes ces questions
auxquels nous devons apporter des
réponses nous les avons soulevé cette
année côté législatif mais nous avons
été bloqués par certaines institutions
maintenant et je suis persuadé que cette
présidence française du conseil de l'ue
agira dans ce sens nous allons pouvoir
débloquer la situation et arriver à des
accords entre le parlement européen et
le conseil de l'union européenne sur ces
sujets spécifiques parce que les
citoyens européens attendent de nous des
réponses il ya un autre grand sujet de
polémique sur votre île à l'anc une
enquête indépendante qui porte sur le
meurtre de daphné karuna galicia et a
été rendu public accusant l'ancien
gouvernement maltais dirigé par le
travail joseph muscat d'être en partie
responsable de la mort de sept
journalistes assassinés en 2000
17il elle fustige au passage la culture
de l'impunité à malte est ce que on va
trouver finalement qui a ordonné ce
meurtre et puis qu'est ce que est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec cette idée qu'il
y a de l'impunité
fourmies
moi et pour le parlement également juste
après l'assassinât de daphné caruana
gallizia et l'assassinât de yan kuszak
quelques mois plus tard en slovaquie ils
étaient des journalistes d'investigation
qui enquêtait et traquer la corruption
dans les plus hautes sphères y compris
dans les sphères politiques
ce parlement a été très clair sur le
fait qu'il allait faire tout ce qui
était en son pouvoir pour que justice
soit rendue et pour envoyer ce message
aux journalistes de tous les pays de
l'union que nous sommes là pour les
protéger et faire en sorte que là où il
y a des vides juridiques dans les
législations nationales y compris dans
mon propre pays nous proposeront des
législations pour les combler
ou est elle nous en sommes encore très
loin et c'est pourquoi j'ai tenu lors de
ma première visite officielle à malte à
me rendre sur le lieu même de
l'assassinât de daphné caruana gallizia
avec sa famille ses parents ses enfants
son mari pour réitérer mon engagement
car je n'arrêterai pas de chercher et ce
parlement n'arrêtera pas de chercher
tant que nous n'aurons pas trouvé qui
doit porter la responsabilité de son
assassinat d' merci d'avoir été notre
invité aujourd'hui roberta mezzo la
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis pour
cet entretien de france 24 vous restez
sur nos antennes
[Musique]